why don't we try nick from new york next
nick you're on the air
uh hi david hello going i'm doing well
thank you
um i was just wondering i've been trying
to ask you this question
what is the best way to pass voting
rights legislation without
the supreme court striking it down
why would the supreme court strike it
down like hr1
you know conservatives like to argue
that it's unconstitutional
right but conservatives often argue that
things
are unconstitutional and they're just
wrong
yeah what do they say is
unconstitutional about hr one
they say that well they they force
states to
um you know change their
redistricting rules and you know
make them have all these sorts of things
having to do with voting my position on
this is make them prove it's
unconstitutional make them actually do
it because
just republicans saying it's
unconstitutional to me it's it's just
not good enough
and if they actually want to fight that
make them do the work uh i don't think
it's a reason not to push for hr one and
i
i hope it passes and put put republicans
in the position of having to actually
uh sue and appeal and appeal and appeal
i wouldn't be scared away by that
but what makes you know the federal
government
mandating that states change their
election laws
constitutionally well the the the
problem is the framing
so republicans frame it as
hr1 would be the federal government
telling states how to run elections
there's a completely different way to
understand it which is
the federal government much like with
the voting rights act which was
completely constitutional
can set basic parameters and
guidelines that must be met by states
for their constitutions to be considered
fair and valid and
that held with the voting rights act and
there's no reason to believe in
particular that it wouldn't hold with
hr1 i mean
maybe aspects of hr1 would be found
unconstitutional but the argument you're
repeating is not a very strong one
yeah i'm i'm simply just trying to
you know debunk these these um
these talking of course of course yeah
no i i
just make them prove it make them prove
it is the point
okay um and i would like to ask you
another thing
okay um what is um
i i am wondering why don't you mention
how joe manchin and kirsten cinema are
bought out by
corporations i don't see you talk about
that we do i mean i know less about
cinema but joe manchin and west virginia
business interests are something we have
talked about before
um i think maybe if you're not hearing
me talk about it as much recently
it it it's sort of i mean i don't it's
not as much a part of the big picture if
you have something where there are even
more democrats that aren't on board or
you need
60 so it's not even about just democrats
but at least as far as joe manchin goes
we have talked about that
all right um yeah all right my friend
thank you very much for the call i
appreciate it
one of our sponsors is hydrant which is
a delicious
fruit drink powder that you mix into
water for rehydration and they're giving
you 25
off your first order it's made with four
key electrolytes that the body needs
powerfully supporting your hydration
hydrant tastes great
it's made with real fruit juice it's
been a great part of my daily routine
for a while now
keeping myself hydrated puts me in a
better mood
the body needs hydration for basic
energy and focus and hydrant is the
perfect way to rehydrate
especially because it's cost effective
and lower in sugar compared to all of
those popular
sports drinks that are out there you
really have to try it for yourself to
see what i mean
it tastes great they also have a variety
called hydrant immunity
packed with vitamins a b c and d
which is also very much worth trying
hydrant has a full refund guarantee if
you're not satisfied and you'll get 25
off your first order when you go to
drink hydrant.com
pacman or just enter the code pacman at
checkout
i've put the link right underneath this
video